hello and welcome to this short
educational film you have either
requested to be transferred to site 50
to conduct cutting-edge research or you
have been volunteered by the foundation
congratulations let's begin this tour
with a quick history lesson as we
explore your new facility I'll hand this
over to dr. Penn diem for a quick
overview good afternoon
firstly we are located deep deep
underground so do enjoy the sunshine
while you can this site began as a
simple stop at holding location for
anomalous objects and entities to be
transferred off site to a sizeable
network of subway tunnels as YC PS were
discovered the site expanded operations
until 1948 but was rebuilt creative
revolutionary state of the art facility
dedicated to initial capture containment
and research into newly discovered
scps and now I shall pass you on to dr.
yes present-day site 50 is renowned in
the foundation as the go-to site for
taking newly discovered anomalous
objects in North America
it has the highest collection of
underground transport tunnels connecting
to sites worldwide for safe deliveries
of SCPs
we even have a new temporary naming
system for the scps
while they are in holding as we
cross-reference their traits to make
sure they haven't been discovered yet
as you can see site 50 truly is the
place to be I'm sure you'll enjoy your
time here experience the most advanced
fields of modern science and safety that
the foundation has to offer here at site
50 welcome aboard
[Music]